immer wieder warnen experten vor
großveranstaltungen aber wie groß sind
die auswirkungen dann auf das
infektionsgeschehen darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit professor dr klaus dieter
zastrow herzlich willkommen und auch er
an sie zuerst einmal die frage welche
auswirkungen befürchten sie nun die die
auswirkung könnte natürlich sein wenn da
20 30.000 menschen ohne maske unterwegs
sind
das gegebenenfalls beschlussfähige
teilweise die pandemie weiter betrieben
wird jedenfalls dass wir weitere
zusätzliche unnötige fälle dann in
deutschland bekommen
ich will aber doch noch mal eins ganz
klar stellen
wir hatten ja am anfang haben sie
übertragen
zwei junge leute die erklärt haben warum
sie gegen die masken sind leider muss
man sagen dass alles was sie dort
vorgetragen haben gänzlich völlig falsch
und unzutreffend ist also die begründung
die argumente die sie gegen die maske
liefern sind alle viel gängig aber jetzt
auch noch mal ganz klar auch im
öffentlich rechtlichen fernsehen wird
tagtäglich kommen die leute zu wort die
erzählen die poren sind zu groß die
viren sind zu leihen das funktioniert
alles gar nicht also ich kann das auch
verstehen diese fehlinformationen von
sogenannten fachleuten die dann
öffentlich übertragen werden und wenn
die leute sich das angucken und nichts
anderes dann verstehe ich die an dieser
stelle auch also jedenfalls die
argumente sind völlig viel gängig die
maske ist genau die sache die der
brauchen weil wir nichts anderes haben
wir haben keine impfung wir haben auch
keine medikamente und natürlich sind
solche massenveranstaltungen
wie wir sie jetzt da haben die ohne
maske gezielt ohne maske erfolgen sind
natürlich auch gefährlich für das ist
weitere epidemische geschehen in
deutschland ja doch das heißt noch mal
zur einordnung dass eben gerade
angesprochen haben waren demonstranten
die eben auf der demonstration gegen die
korona regeln sind und die dort erklärt
haben warum sie nicht an die maske
glauben sie konnten das jetzt noch mal
medizinisch widerlegen die tatsachen auf
den tisch legen und auch die polizei
möchte er jetzt dagegen vorgehen hat
jetzt getwittert dass die demonstranten
bitte eine maske tragen müssen also mit
der bitte eine maske zu tragen wenn dort
wie sehen sie das aus ärztlicher sicht
ist sind jedoch sehr sehr viele
demonstranten verordnen hat mit rund
30.000 gerechnet einschätzungen zufolge
könnten es weitaus mehr sein die stehen
dort eng an eng weil es teilweise auch
nicht weitergeht hier sehen wir auch
nochmal den treter polizei
wie sehen sie das aus medizinischer
sicht selbst wenn man dann dort die
maske tragen tragen würde was ja die
demonstranten auch bedauerlicherweise
nicht tun
wie hoch ist denn dann das
ansteckungsrisiko also so wie sie ist
jetzt im moment machen dass sie nicht
tragen ist ein riesiges
übertragungsrisiko bestehen in der dicht
beieinander unterhalten sich sehr
lautstark natürlich auch und rufen
irgendwelche parolen bei denen man
natürlich eher o sohle auch freisetzen
kann oder damen wir besser tröpfchen
freisetzen kann also die situation so
wie sie jetzt ist ist natürlich
verheerend und katastrophal wenn alle
eine maske tragen würden dann wäre gar
nichts
hätten wir überhaupt kein risiko da
spielt dann der abstand auch gar keine
rolle denn die maske hält die tröpfchen
zurück in die eine richtung wie in die
andere wenn alle masken tragen kann
überhaupt gar nichts passiert und das
muss man sich vor augen halten und es
wird aber keiner bestreiten dass es
tatsächlich gibt obwohl manch einer sagt
das dann
wir haben die erkrankungen ja in
deutschland nicht in den massen wie wir
sie befürchtet haben aus italien
aber das liegt ihm auch an der maske und
wenn wir die nicht hätten dann hätten
wir sehr schnell wieder ein lockdown die
maske bringt uns eigentlich die freiheit
genau wo gegen die leute demonstrieren
genau das bringt uns die
maske die freiheit bringt uns die maske
es gab ja um diese demo ein ziemliches
hin und her der berliner senat hat sie
verboten das verwaltungsgericht hat die
entscheidung gekippt aus ihrer sicht ist
es gut dass diese demo hatte stattfindet
ja ich finde das in ordnung aber sie
müsste natürlich unter den regeln
ablaufen ja wir wollen ja den leuten
denke ich nicht das demonstrationsrecht
nicht man muss auch seine freie meinung
äußern können es kann ja auch jeder
sagen ich mag die maske nicht aber
sinnvoll ist sie trotzdem
und wir halten auch bei roter ampel auch
immer etwas eiliger haben
also insofern die regeln müssen doch die
starts regeln müssen eingehalten werden
aber wir haben ja auch eine gute
medizinische berührung ist er dich
einfach aus der luft gegriffen dass er
seine maske war gerade den launen darauf
haben nein sie hörten sie schützt unsere
bevölkerung und das geht auch aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz davor
allgemeinwohl gibt vereinzelt diese
sachen die da erzählt wurde man kriegt
pilz ist alles untersucht worden ist
alles blödsinn
wir atmen doch das in die maske hinein
was aus unserem körper aus kommt dann
müssen wir innerlich schon schwer krank
sei also ist alles schluss aber
natürlich wird auch das veröffentlicht
und der eine oder andere ist nicht voll
informiert obwohl die darüber wundere
denn es gibt ja internet da kann man
alles nachlesen
also wir müssen die leute ruhig
demonstrieren lassen aber sie sollen
sich bitte an die regeln halten und auch
den mund nasen schutz bei so einer
demonstration tragen
professor hat derzeit pro vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ja ja